you
[Music]
so I'm gonna talk today about how we can
accelerate the process of building
machine learning models by changing the
way that we create a managed training
data for them and the motivation at a
very high level is that trainee data is
often the key ingredient and
increasingly the key bottleneck in
building machine learning pipelines but
for something that's such a key
ingredient it's it's increasingly or
it's sorry largely created and managed
in almost entirely manual or ad-hoc ways
and so the question the research
question that a lot of the work that
we've done at the Stanford site is
anchored around is a simple one can we
add a little bit of mathematical and
system structure so the way that people
in the real world build and manage their
training sets and can we use this to
lead into new ways of interacting with
the machine learning stack so I'll start
with a running example I want to try to
stay somewhat agnostic to what the
particular application is because
snorkels really somewhat orthogonal to
or the systems i'll talk about are about
training data for machine learning
models and what those models are we can
get into the the definitions but you
know we approach it at a very high level
but I'll ground it in an example that
I'm excited about these days so despite
some journal rejections it it is at
least posted and I'm quite excited by
this radiology application we've been
working on with the Stanford hospital
system and a couple of other local
systems were rolling out for deployment
the motivation really concretely is
we're trying to do case prioritization
so no no nonsense about replacing
radiologists tomorrow all about
assistance through prioritization in
triaging so simple way that an ml model
fits into the stack we have a chest
x-ray and we just want to train a model
to do binary classification there's kind
of the simplest version just a
supervised learning problem and again
this can be a big help even in the short
term in terms of actually affecting how
we prioritize cases to be read say find
emergent ones and get them to doctors
sooner so the standard way you'd go
about this kind of a pipeline this kind
of you know converge today I'm
definitely glossing over details and
complexities where there's a lot of cool
work going on but to a first-order
abstraction you start with unlabeled
data in this case I'll mention this
becomes relevant later that's multimodal
and that it's it's a it's not just the
images it's also metadata blobs of text
etc
along with it we pay or in our case beg
are our kindly radiology collaborators
to spend a bunch of time labeling the
training set you know looking at the
images and labeling normal abnormal etc
and then you know they built a model in
this case it was a ResNet this is a
classification model to actually train
based on that label data so the
interesting thing first of all is that
you know what I entered grad school say
five ish years ago it kind of block out
the exact number but somewhere
thereabouts this would be sort of where
you know where we were gonna research
right how do you do feature engineering
for these models how do you actually
build the algorithms etc today it's
almost commodity right I know that's a
bit of an out there and and you know I'm
intending that as a provocative
statement but it's it's increasingly
true that you know if you want to build
one of these state-of-the-art image
classification models you just you know
it's like two lines of Python if you set
it up right using Python or sorry pi
torch or tensorflow or MX net or any of
the other models and the case are in
this case our radiology collaborators
really only took about two or three days
modulo the overnight training time to
get a reasonable solution and actually
then when they went back and they looked
at a basically five plus years of deep
learning architecture progress and
imaging from you know trying hallux net
all the way up to res net and dense net
for those who are familiar with these
these architecture names there's only
about a one you know one point
difference in terms of the end roc AUC
predictive accuracy score so this is a
common theme that we're seeing a lot of
settings where model development is
actually radically easier than it was
before and it's not really the thing
that's the key differentiator to keep
bottleneck in terms of getting something
to work
on the other hand I'm sure you could
guess where the punch line was coming in
at they spent about eight person months
even on this simple binary chest x-ray
triage problem just labeling the
training set and interestingly enough
when we actually looked at the
difference between say a couple thousand
labelled data points and then the full
hundred K plus labeled training data
points they they produced after eight
months there's about an order of
magnitude larger differential than the
choice of the fancy model architecture
similarly when we actually stepped in
and tried to improve the quality of the
training labels and I'll get into much
more depth about what I mean by quality
it was a similar sort of order of
magnitude larger effect on the
score so again in a large variety of
settings not all but many ones that we
care about training data is the the key
bottleneck and the key differentiator of
how this added performance or how this
ad model performs so just to make this a
little bit more concrete what we're
motivated by what we're trying to sort
of build around there are three
challenges of training data management
most broadly it's not just labeling the
data but managing and in general the
first is that volume is critical as I
went over but it's often incredibly slow
and expensive to get the volume you need
right most problems are not actually
just sending data out to Turkish where
you can pay kind of lower prices but
they're asking people like radiologists
or cybersecurity analysts or or or etc
who have domain expertise and often need
to be on prem to actually label the data
by hand over months or years and that
great cost quality is critical but it's
challenging to assess almost sounds kind
of circular i'll get into some of the
the interesting theoretical questions
there and also something that's often I
think massively underpriced and academic
ml is that flexibility is critical right
so the traditional conception it's it's
a great abstraction but the traditional
conception of training data is just a
bunch of labeled X Y pairs no chest
x-rays and a label of normal abnormal
and it's just incompletely static but in
any real-world condition or almost any
railroad condition this changes and then
you need to update your training set
which usually means just throw it out
and start over again so just a really
simple example here is you know we had
normal abnormal that was where the
schema we were training the model for
and then the hospitalist we were
piloting with came back and said
actually we want more buckets right we
want to break abnormal into emergency or
non-emergency right and we had no real
good way and and in general people don't
have a good real a real good way to
handle this other than just throw out
the training labels start over again and
this is ditto if I you have a model as
part of a broader pipeline and you have
upstream or downstream changes if I've
actually had a three-star general who's
visiting Stanford talked about the
problem of schema lock-in of having to
spend a lot of money on training day
than getting getting locked into a
schema the data distribution changes the
devices and say I'm medical imaging
setting change really anything there's
not really a lot of flexibility in the
paradigm of just a big labeled training
set or hand labeled training set so the
research that we do at the lab at
Stanford that I've worked on for last
five years is building systems that
basically try to address these
challenges or fulfill these desert
errata using kind of a three-step
high-level blueprint so first is that we
want to let user specify training sets
in higher level and programmatic ways
rather than by hand the second is we
want to do something in a principled way
to clean and integrate this kind of
higher level Messier input and then
finally we want to be able to plug this
into the the machine learning stack
where there's been so much progress and
investment in tooling in the last five
ten years and we found that by following
this kind of blueprint we can actually
get new ways to program or specify
machine learning models that actually
lead to the development of nm pipelines
and hours or days rather than months or
years so in this talk specifically I'm
going to talk about three systems that
support and accelerate critical steps of
the training data management pipeline
more broadly so the first one and I'll
be focusing on supervised learning right
so this is in contrast to say you know
Ray that we just saw where it's a you
know some ways a broader you know set up
of reinforcement this is just your sort
of vanilla bread-and-butter ml pipeline
where you know I would argue from
experiences what the bulk of sort of
production applications today run on
just you know learn to classify this
with a certain label or a scalar value
so labeling is really important here
obviously that's the central activity
I'm also going to talk about saying
called data augmentation if you look at
image applications and increasingly
other modalities this is the idea that
you can kind of artificially boost the
size of your training set by perturbing
or transforming data points like
rotating all your images randomly it's
actually kind of an interesting way a
new way of injecting invariances into
your knowledge of invariances into your
model via the training data and then
also talk briefly about multitask
supervision which is just kind of you
know revisiting the old idea of wanting
to transfer information between models
and actually train one model that does
multiple things to get more from less
less samples or less signal and I'll
spend the bulk of the time talking about
the system that I've worked on over the
last five years at Stanford called
snorkle there's an open source system
for trying to let users programmatically
label training data or rather to support
that that emerging process that we see
out there in the world and I'll just
talk briefly
a system for you know sort of also
supporting data augmentation and letting
people put in operators about
transformations and then tune that
automatically and then also a recent
system we've been working on actually I
just got a state of the art on a
multitask learning benchmark called
snorkel metal which extends snorkel into
the the setting where you have multiple
tasks you care about that you want to
kind of handle jointly and also
mentioned deployments that we've used to
both motivate and validate these these
systems in particular snorkel and
industry government and science and
medicine so I'll start with snorkel and
again the problem also again please just
stop me if want to ask questions so the
problem and I apologize in advance for
being congested actually the whole
reason for the name snorkel is that I
had proposed it and then I thought ah I
had a cold at the time and I was like
that I sent a god-awful saying that out
loud and at which point my adviser said
and I will veto any other name because I
want you to have to stand front of
people and say snorkel with a cold and
sound ridiculous so here I am okay the
problem again motivating this is that
you know hand labeling training in but
that critical sort of step in the
process of building an end-to-end ml
pipeline it's really slow and expensive
and it's static right in real-world
settings that's that's often very
prohibitive and so the simple idea that
we're motivated by here is trying to
enable users to label training data
programmatically rather than by hand and
the key technical idea undergirding this
is that we're going to view training
sets not as this sort of you know
perfect noiseless object that we
download from the internet and then get
to work training our fancy model
architecture but rather as a noisy
programmatic process itself that we can
model and denoise and so we
operationalize this in three main steps
the first is that rather than having
user's hand label data we have them
write what we call labeling functions
these are very semantically poor basic
objects just you know at the at the
basic level that we handled them they're
just blackbox functions that take in an
unlabeled data point and either abstain
or apply a label and the second step we
work on trying to clean and combine
these labels basically take the output
of the different labeling functions and
learn how much to trust each of the
labeling functions which
functions are correlated and therefore
how should we re waiting combine their
their outputs and on the output we call
sometimes a training database at stores
a bunch of labels as well as the lineage
or the provenance from the sources they
come from and their quality and then we
can just basically plug this into you
know PI torch tensorflow etc yes
[Music]
that's that's exactly the interesting
question so I'll get into that and and
if I don't give a clear answer I bring
it up again
yes when you functions you're writing
each example let's say so one example
that comes in you can get back a number
of potential labels zeros or ones let's
say a binary and then you're saying that
the simple system makes a decision on
which is the best label to apply for
that example exactly exactly so you know
just to sort of get right size there
order of magnitude it's like you know
maybe a domain extra rights you know 20
labeling functions right and so you have
they can abstain but you know you might
have you know five ten different labels
that conflict and disagree and are
correlated for any data point and we're
looking how do we relate and combine
them right in the simplest form it's
just you know I want to take a weighted
majority vote basically break ties
figure out which ones to trust yes maybe
have an image that doesn't get any label
I do it after all these labels this in
that case would that be kind of manually
labeled as it would be in the previous
process and then you can use like a
blend of the two yes oh that's great I
mean generally the idea of blending
different orthogonal approaches is a
broader question that we could discuss
it's very interesting of you know well
we've applied snorkel we think of as
weak supervision along with things like
semi-supervised learning active learning
is another orthogonal thing that you can
do in this framework there's lots of
cool things you can just add a high
level data blending approaches together
this includes strong supervision right
you can dump in labels if you have them
so all emphasize a lot that snorkel
doesn't require any hand label training
data actually there it is that's kind of
the provocative and interesting bit on
the theoretical and academic side and it
ends up being very useful in practice
when it's very expensive to bride labels
but again if you have them you can dump
them in in fact a bunch of labels
especially ones you don't know if you
should trust could be a labeling
function the second thing you brought up
is what if all the labeling functions
abstain and that's where we rely on this
final model to try to generalize a bit
and I'll get into that as well
so let me proceed now and then I'm going
to kind of go into each of these buckets
and then we should revisit some of these
these questions some of them are very
interesting and deep so I'll mention
just briefly you know we've deployed
snorkel a lot over the last four years
it's open source so
these it's kind of got a there's an
artifact online at snorkel that
stanford.edu you can check it out along
the papers and stuff it's sort of a
version that we had from about two years
ago based around the text extraction
type problems then we've deployed
various versions of it in science and
medicine with the Stanford hospital
system and the VA system and a bunch of
other partner labs we've collaborated
with in industry it's being used in
production at Google and Facebook and
Intel so I'm not sure Facebook PSU
Google and Intel Microsoft and financial
IBM and some others that have been
longtime collaborators and also in some
government settings like it's being
deployed in the DARPA Memex pipeline at
the DOJ for pulling out data from online
pages of to fight anti-human trafficking
so part of that pipeline amongst others
and in many of these cases the sort of
bullet point takeaway is that we can
actually take an end-to-end process from
sort of starting a new problem to
training a model that used to be if you
actually counted all of the steps you
know person months or longer and turn
this thing that's more in the order of
hours or days of sign that looks more
like programming so now I'll go I'll go
through the three steps and give a
little bit more detail so the first step
is this idea of a labeling function so
at the most abstract level is just a
function that maps from your input data
point to your output space where you're
trying to make predictions in or abstain
again abstain just means I don't know
and I'll just denote it by a zero here
and so it's just meant to be a simple
abstraction for expressing domain
expertise or other sort of noisy sources
of data and again it's very semantically
poor we we started thinking okay we will
do something with first-order logic or
some kind of like declarative query
language or etc it's still of interest
but we really just said okay we want to
let the developer be creative and kind
of just dump in whatever signal they
have and then try to deal with that in a
simple basic way so it's a really simple
function and I'll give an example right
so I imagine that we have the text
portion of one of those those case
studies from the hospital packs a
picture archiving system and here is a
labeling function actually written by a
clinical radiology fellow with some
basic Python knowledge that was a user
and collaborator on this project and
this one just says look for the prefix
pneumo in the text just a pattern match
function and if you see it say abnormal
so that's what I'll denote by this red X
so label any functions again are just
really simple user-defined functions
again the intuition is we'd like to just
express something that's in the labelers
head in a more information dense way
than just sort of you know
yes-no yes-no labels over a huge set of
course these labeling functions can be
wrong this one obviously misses the
negation outputs the wrong answer and
again the key that I'll get into in the
next step of the pipelines that labeling
functions can be noisy they can they can
actually be noisy to varying the unknown
degrees and if we have a couple of them
that are sufficiently uncorrelated we
can we can handle this
but before diving in there I'll just
mention that um you know the intention
with these labeling functions was to
sort of provide a simple abstraction and
framework for a lot of what's often been
called weak supervision techniques that
are used in practice often and creative
but ad-hoc ways so this includes pattern
matching to label data this includes
something that's called distance
supervision in the natural language
processing community this is at a rough
level the idea that you take an existing
knowledge base and map it to your data
to label it here as a simple example
I'll note these are all labeling
functions that were written as part of
that radiology project with the clinical
fellow this one just says look take an
online ontology from the nih of disease
phrases cross it with the words and the
blob that the nurse or doctor dictated
and if there's an overlap return
abnormal right so you can imagine this
one would be very high coverage it
doesn't abstain that often kind of low
signal but still has some something
useful we can express domain heuristics
like if the report the text along with
it is really short it's probably not an
emergency those three were over the text
portion we can also let people write
labeling functions or express their
domain knowledge over more complex
modalities so I can get more in depth
later on in the questions but we had a
paper where we were doing first we just
applied a lot of off-the-shelf
unsupervised algorithms to images and
that let users write labeling functions
over those black sort of building blocks
or primitives so for example we can
write one that says okay if this sort of
circle detector finds a circle with a
large radius in the image labeled
abnormal give us a rough way of
expressing the intuition if there's a
big blob in the images problem
we bad and again you know we can take
crowd-sourced labels we can take other
models that might be low coverage or
brittle or biased dump them in as
labeling functions and the result is
that rather than having you know a
hundred thousand or ten million hand
labelled examples again that we pretty
much have to throw out if we if
something changes or really there's any
question about an issue with them we
have supervision in the form of code
right and it comes with all the you know
resulting benefits of being more
interpretable more modifiable more yeah
much faster to write but of course the
trade-off is that it's a very very messy
type of supervision so just to give a
sense of those challenges more
concretely imagine we this report again
here are three of those labeling
functions challenge number one is that
these labeling functions have different
accuracies right and they often agree
disagree with each other and here if we
even just tried to take say a majority
vote of their labels we would get the
wrong answer the second problem is that
they can have correlations that are kind
of subtle so here for example just a
dive in this one is looking for the word
pneumothorax basically a type of disease
that's pretty much where my medical
knowledge ends here we're just saying
okay cross-check with this disease
ontology could imagine it that if this
ontology contains pneumothorax
then there's basically a logical
relation between these two and if you
counted them as sort of uncorrelated
sources of signal you'd be double
counting their votes and finally we have
to try to handle these things without
any ground truth again we may have it I
can get into that it's fairly easy to
incorporate but the chat the the context
we consider is that we just have these
noisy labels we don't have a large
ground truth labeled set right otherwise
we would just use that to train our
model in the first place so we've used a
new type of data cleaning an integration
problem and the next step is basically
how we solve this and the question to
anchor on here is is how we do this
without ground truth labels so this is
where I'm going to skip through some
stuff that I get very excited about but
most other people in the world don't and
I can always circle back to it if we
actually want to step through it but
jokes aside it's honest I think it's
more interesting just to talk high level
and then have discussions based off of
that so let's see I'll give the high
level sketch is that we view we
represent this kind of black box set of
labeling functions and the noisy labels
the output and then again there's
arbitrary logic within them as a really
simple generative process where there's
some true unobserved variable or a
latent variable that's the true label
that we don't see and then some observed
random variables corresponding to the
output labels of the labeling functions
our goal is to recover some parameters
that describe okay what accurate what
with what accuracy do these observed
labels correspond to the true label I'll
talk about here well I guess I'm gonna
skip through most of this but I'm gonna
talk about just a single parameter just
okay we're trying to learn one accuracy
for each labeling function we can do
much more interesting extensions of that
for example we might want to learn that
different labeling functions are good in
different parts of the data space right
we might want to learn data conditional
accuracies will also include pairwise
dependencies so and in this brief part
that I'll skip through you know we
assume that we kind of know these edges
but we've done a lot of work one
hopefully two papers soon on statistical
approaches to learning those
correlations again the key question is
here how do we learn the model how do we
learn the accuracies and the
correlations of these labeling functions
these really messy black box objects
under this simple model of the process
but when we don't actually observe the
ground truth label and there's a lot of
prior work on this a lot of it from the
crowdsourcing community
let's get by this there's lots online we
have about this this is the main thing
I'll present at this point which is that
the key idea that we anchor around here
and this is you know something that is a
kind of an old idea at the highest level
is that we want to learn from the
agreements and disagreements between the
labeling functions and only learn from
that right so we don't know what you
know if we knew the ground truth label
we could just count right I want to know
how accurate this labeling function is
I'll just count up how many times it's
right and how many times it's wrong
right
because we don't have the ground truth
label we're just looking at the the
record of how they agree and disagree
with each other and actually from that
we can provably recover under basic
settings the accuracies and the
correlations of these labeling functions
so I'm going to skip by this but I can
go back there's a new approach that we
recently presented on how to do this but
I'll kind of sketch the the ending point
here and again I'm happy to loop back
afterwards or this is all online the
result is that we get a problem and and
just for some of you this might kind of
look familiar and that it kind of looks
like a matrix completion problem which
has been a lot of you know it's not a
it's not a nice you know convex problem
it's kind of nasty and its own right but
there's been a lot of work both
theoretically and empirically on how to
solve this kind of a thing or I think
like Netflix challenge that kind of that
kind of line of work so one reason it's
it's nice is that we can actually
recover solve this nasty problem of
learning the accuracies and the
correlations just using basic stochastic
gradient descent in a form that we kind
of know it's also scalable this is just
I'll mention briefly but if n is the
number of unlabeled data points that we
have so the number of that you know
basically in the radiology example say
the number of case studies that we have
that we apply these labeling functions
to and D is the number of roughly
labeling functions or correlations
between them you know so think like 20
30 something on that order if this
doesn't make sense with the part that I
skipped over so much but basically we
have these these much smaller matrices
that we're actually optimizing over so
basically first we compute the
agreements and disagreements which is
this Sigma which is just matrix algebra
and that's fairly fast and then all the
ML kind of optimization components of
this are really over these tiny matrices
relatively speaking and then finally we
actually show some theoretical
guarantees that we can we can provide
for these settings and I'll just give a
sketch of this this will be the only
part of the the theoretical
jibber-jabber that I go into here but
the your basic sketch of the result that
we drive towards in some of the sort of
you know theory papers here is that if
we have n of these unlabeled data points
so again just like the unlabeled case
studies on the on the PAC system at the
hospital or you know the number of
documents were trying to classify that
don't have labels for example and then
we assume second that we have a set of
labeling functions that are on average
better than random right so if we assume
that if there are 11 labeling functions
the subject matter expert or user rights
that just six of them are are better
than 50% accurate right at least and for
those that are familiar these sensor
problems it's just a way of breaking
some final sign symmetry that you have
to deal with and finally this is the
this sounds kind of tangled but this
actually has also masked back to kind of
a real-world question for for developers
and this kind of a pipeline so the
statement is that we also assume there's
a sufficiently sparse dependency
structure between the labeling functions
all this means is the following here
I'll just sketch them intuition so you
could imagine that this graph bless you
would look like okay every labeling
function has a correlation between
pairwise a really bad very extreme
version of this would be imagine if you
just dumped in identical copies of
labeling functions right so you really
only have one source of signal but you
just have ten copies of it or something
you would guess that we can't really do
anything there right and that that's
correct right snorkel is not going to
learn anything at least in this part of
the pipeline on the other hand if you
have a bunch of this model would
correspond to labeling functions that
are completely conditionally independent
meaning they're they're completely
uncorrelated in their errors this is a
model PETA people often use to model
crowd workers right there just sitting
off in their own rooms polluting or or
sharing notes at all in this case where
they really are uncorrelated signals
this is you know lots of work has been
done on this whether it's in finance or
crowdsourcing or whatever you'd guess
this would be good so the question we
ran into it with users was okay well how
do we know where we are and and what is
enough what it what is sort of what is
you know when are we okay and that we
have enough uncorrelated signal to do
something again just intuitively you
need to have some independent views of
the problem to be able to do anything in
this kind of modeling procedure so we
provide a deterministic test for this
that basically either tells the user
almost like a compiler
you know you have diverse enough
labeling functions or you don't you
better come back and get some more
sources of signal and then what we show
is that actually the estimation error of
recovering these accuracies and
correlations decreases asymptotically
with the more unlabeled data we put in
at the same asymptotic rate as you
traditionally show for the supervised
learning setting so high level this says
a we actually have something that you
know we have theoretical reason to
believe will actually converge on like
some settings where you're playing
tricks to label data and second that
actually will Bennett we should benefit
theory says that we should benefit from
dumping in more unlabeled data and
running it through the labeling
functions simple simple takeaways but
I'll get back to the some empirical
results that that follow from this okay
so anyway just to recap and again happy
to dive in more detail about the the
actual approach that I skipped over but
we have these labeling functions these
kind of noisy little programs black
boxes that just output messy labels we
model them as a simple process where
they they have accuracies and potential
correlations we show that we can solve
this using a matrix completion style
problem that we kind of know how to
handle and then given that we can use
you know basic techniques just to get a
probabilistic label basically a way to
reweighed and combine the labeling
functions labels yes number of
independent labeling function
it's a great question um the more the
better actually so the more you know if
you if you just keep throwing
independent labeling functions by a kind
of law of large numbers type intuition
you know you could just take a majority
vote and we actually have a little
treatment of that of you know if you
have twenty or thirty labeling functions
snorkel gives you a much bigger boost
over some simpler approach say just
majority voting if you have like
thousands of labeling functions you
could just kind of add them up and and
if they're really uncorrelated you know
simple stuff works that's a great
question
the cool thing is that you don't need
them to be really accurate you just it's
actually more important to have
uncorrelated kind of diverse sources of
signals than it is important to have
like really high accuracy you could have
a whole bunch of labeling questions that
are sixty percent accurate but if
they're truly uncorrelated this this can
work right yes
yes so I'm curiously something that
easily weakly - suffice
I is that is that not gonna be just made
up or is that an existing one please
it's a thing that I'm ready to be
impressed but we wrote something called
diesel for a company that we worked at I
woke up we leveraged most a lot of your
work on the first pass but that fact
that we found was that we learned a lot
yeah I'm gonna prove I didn't have any
functions by just allowing our users to
iterate incorporated someday yeah yeah
no that's awesome and I'd love to talk
afterwards I'll try to pounce afterwards
um the mostly cuz that's an amazing
acronym almost made a stoat joke there
that would have been really truly
terrible but um yeah the we've done that
I mean you know one thing that I guess
doesn't come out well in this version of
talk is that this is always an iterative
process right we're in a sense that you
know a phrase another way the goal of
this project was to support what we saw
as an emerging development process right
we saw people kind of hacking together
training sets from different sources of
different qualities of label sets we saw
ourselves and others we worked with at
Google and you know other places you
know kind of taking programmatic ways of
labeling data and we said okay would you
want to support that right so it always
ends up being iterative putting that
more on Rails so we can both support it
better and analyze it better is
something that we've done a lot of but
you know in different pieces I have a
project right now where where I'm
working with someone at Stanford and
Percy Lane group who's working on he
does active learning theory so we're
thinking about okay what is it what is
the active learning version probably
similar what you did but more from the
kind of theory perspective what does
that look like right we're traditional
active learning you're saying okay I
want to get I want to find out what data
point do I ask for a label for here
we're saying what what set of points do
I show to a user to get them to write a
labeling function in the most sort of
helpful part of the space so yeah I'd
love to chat afterwards but it's
definitely I mean like it's always
iterative and putting that more on Rails
is just an ongoing bit of work it ends
have also been saying that is very
important on the engineering side so
when we actually go in productize this
with partners who use it and bring it
internally like Google or Intel or
others a big big part of that ends up
being how you put that process on Rails
probably similar to what you worked on
cool so that was that section and then
the final section I'll just give a
little intuition about some of the
interesting stuff here this is for the
database our data management folks in
the room of the lineage is a word that
community likes are we like but a simple
example just to illustrate that is okay
well imagine we have one set of labeling
functions
that label a million points so they
don't abstain that much but at 60%
accuracy and then we have one set of
points that label sort of 10,000 points
at 90 percent accuracy and we just dump
these in and treat them identically well
then you could imagine that the average
training Lea black you see is barely
better than 60% right the the high
quality low coverage ones get diluted so
this is really frustrating if you are a
user like you know I and other
collaborators where the Syst of an early
version of the system you're dumping in
more sort of really high accuracy
sources and your model performance is
not budging right so there's one little
solution and we use basically
probabilistic labels and there's a
really simple tweak to kind of integrate
and pass on this quality knowledge or
this lineage information to the final
model so here for example you know in
standard empirical risk minimization the
details aren't important but the basic
idea is that okay we would have labels
in our radiology problem that are just
yes/no just hard labels normal or
abnormal right and we would just count
up on every iteration how many mistakes
to the model make and just try to
minimize that sum right that's that's
how you train models to these days
and we just use a really simple tweak
that we called noise aware version of
this where we instead of counting up the
mistakes we have a probabilistic label
that says okay here's the confidence of
it being normal or abnormal and we take
the expected number of mistakes and try
to minimize that sum so this is a simple
one-line tweak in tensor flower pie
torch that lets you pass on the lineage
or quality of the labels to the model
and and and circumvents that kind of
frustrating wall that you'd hit
otherwise awesome okay so what I'm gonna
do in the remaining five minutes is I
will mostly focus on snorkel and I'm
just gonna flash some of the other
projects and the goal there really is
just to I'm happy to talk about them
more in the office hours really just to
kind of give a sense of the diversity of
things people do around training data
and some efforts that we've been working
on to support them briefly I'll mention
this so I'll finish I've been store call
and I'll spent like just a minute or two
breezing through just you know look
quick plugs for the other the other
systems that you can look up later so
one question quickly is that often comes
up here is okay we have this you know
this a procedure this
you know fancy procedure to re wait and
combine the labels and then you get
labels why not just use that right why
are we using the labels to trade another
model and and you know there could be
settings where you would just stop there
the reasons are kind of twofold though
in terms of broad buckets one is that
this model meaning just any model you
can download from the Internet these
days that may have some baked in
knowledge is often can generalize beyond
the labeling functions right so I write
a labeling function it says look for the
word malignant in their reports and if
so label it bad often you can get a
model that either has information baked
in like it knows about synonyms and
therefore can expand beyond the labeling
functions or it can just learn these
co-occurring features from enough
unlabeled data that's where the theory
bit comes in and that's actually
answering that question of what happens
if all the labeling functions abstain
well often the biggest improvement we
get for with this model is actually just
it covers more examples that the
labeling functions don't a second use
case is what I call cross modal transfer
where the labeling functions can be
written over a different feature set
than the final model so I'll show that
with an example and this kind of this
will be the thrilling conclusion of our
of our running radiology example so here
in this chest x-ray well actually our
radiologists really only wrote labeling
functions over the text portion but we
trained a model over the image portion
so at test time when we only had images
and no blobs of text the labeling
functions are useless as a predictor but
the model we trained with them is
actually very useful
this also crops up an industry like we
wrote about it in a recent publication
we put out with with Google around a
couple of deployments there where the
labeling functions were written over one
feature set that we called non servable
features internal features to Google but
we trained a model over a different set
of features that were were servable in
production so this this trick ends up
being quite important in practice and
it's kind of using training data as a
medium of transferring domain knowledge
from one model one modality or set of
features to another just to finish the
punchline this is a line I just like
this project this is the RSC AUC curve
the predictive performance after months
of hand labelled data
for one of these x-ray problems this is
a recent publication from our
collaborators in the radiology
department of stanford after years then
they were out 20 labeling functions over
about eight hours roughly and aggregate
and this is what we get with snorkel so
in one sense this is kind of called eye
popping or embarrassing and that you
know we really replaced your person
years of effort in eight hours
another another sense it should seem
like a very common-sense result that you
should be able to do something smarter
than just labeling data points with
single bit labels right you should be
able to use all the information that's
around them that should seem like
low-hanging fruit and although we do in
snorkels just try to make a platform a
framework for getting that low-hanging
fruit rather than doing these
ridiculously long labeling efforts and
we've done this in you know medical
monitoring with many different
modalities done a lot of work and this
is kind of what shows up online in our
current version that's public there more
is this knowledge based construction of
using snorkel to train models that pull
information out of text or documents and
then a bunch of industry deployments
some of which are published about there
are public briefly I'll mentioned that
as theory kind of pointed to we actually
get scaling we dump in more unlabeled
data right so you can write say 20
labeling functions keep that constant
and you dump in more data that
performance gets better so here this was
a problem over text we dumped in we went
from a couple hundred documents to
63,000 but the same set of labeling
functions got up 20 points in accuracy
then finally you know we asked the
question this is actually make it easier
to use so we set up a a user study a two
day one we had 15 teams come from across
the US and we saw that actually when we
compared novice users who'd never use
storko before
spend two and a half hours writing lien
functions the rest of day learning about
snorkle versus if we just paid people
for seven hours to label data I actually
do about 50% better so that's the high
level bit you know again high level
sketches we're trying to rather than
throwing out all this expert knowledge
and data that's in a domain experts head
or in the organization or just
accessible online and say okay well now
spend months labeling data to get access
to the ml stack we want to actually
create that bridge it's now another way
of viewing this okay so I'll just
briefly mention these other two
how am i on time probably bad okay well
that's a one-minute part so data
augmentation a really simple idea and
this often tree is a pre-processing step
just okay well if I have a you know this
is the emne standard digit
classification task
I just want to classify sixes from nines
let me just rotate them a lot to teach
the model about rotational invariance
effectively rather than baking it into
the the features which I'm no longer in
the new deep learning style of things
defining myself it turns out that
actually you know following the theme
doing this data augmentation amounts for
an order of magnitude more often in
performance gains then actually what
fancy model architecture you choose you
know like the leader boards are fighting
over under a point using data
orientation versus not accounts for like
you know in c-4 are 113 point for points
in average the problem is that it's hard
to tune even though it's so critical
it's treated just as a pre-processing
step but the idea is that we can have
users provide little incremental
transformations and then figure out how
to tune them automatically for new
domains and so rather than labeling
functions we now have transformation
functions I'll skip by the details there
we applied it over it not just images
but texts and also medical settings
using a generative adversarial approach
and that's now in Google's Auto augment
system which kind of new state VR
recently or a version of it and then
finally I'll just give a brief pointer
this is online
we got a recent state of the art with
this but this is a snorkel metal is a
system okay say we don't just want to
classify things as normal as in most
cases you don't just have one label you
want to predict but you actually have a
bunch of related labels we'd like to
also be predicting is there some kind of
consolidation is there some type of
pneumothorax I had no idea that those
mean but they're bad I guess anyway our
doctors care about these kinds of things
for some reason so you know the
interesting thing here is that these
aren't just unrelated tasks these are
logically related this is a toy example
but it's you know expressing a
hierarchical subsumption if one of these
diseases is there this also implies that
normal so the simple question is how do
we approach modeling these multiple
related tasks this is you know picking
up on an old line old lines of work in
this week supervision setting so I'll
skip over the but again the problem is
you know if we have multiple tasks even
if we're using something like snorkel we
still have to write labeling functions
for multiple tasks
but maybe if we handle them all together
we can do better with less and that's
all online and I will conclude there I
had some next step stuff but I will have
to come in to their talk if you want to
hear about that and yeah again the key
idea is that by adding just a little bit
of mathematical and system structure
around this emerging process of training
data creation and management we can
radically accelerate it and make it much
more flexible and usable and so thanks
to all of you for listening
[Applause]
[Music]